little is bring the boat have you been
in how did you get here it began when
our parents told us to take a rickety
trolley to briny beach I have some very
bad news for your children your home was
destroyed in your orphans mass we went
to live with Count Olaf he through aunt
Josephine said the leeches conspired
with s my squad anchor Malia spats he
kidnapped a quagmire of triplets
murdered Jacque sneakin in the village
of foul devotees you can't prove that
Baudelaires I need your help
this is the most important mission VFD
history let's not hesitate you
disappoint us her laugh a little their
fortune is small potatoes no I'm pretty
sure it's money just submarines ready
I will envy FD once and for all
please write by Thursday to the last
safe place so tell Dana ma sail
volunteer
of course we welcome this hotel is
packed with familiar faces our enemies
are getting bolder should all be in
danger
I will get my revenge on everyone
what do you think they're up to baby
blahblah things aren't always what they
see in Baudelaires
our parents were training us for VF teen
we didn't even know it
we can't live on the run forever
don't you have any burning questions
any unsolved mystery
[Music]
don't you want to know what happens next
what happens next
violet Klaus and sunny Baudelaire my
name is lemony snicket this plot
you
you